Turquía mantiene sujeto a la entrada de
la otan de Suecia a Finlandia así lo ha
explicado esta misma tarde el presidente
Turco reserva y perdón que ha recibido
en ankara al Primer Ministro seco ulf
christens explicado que Turquía
considera que Suecia sobre todo Suecia
pero también Finlandia se han convertido
en Estados en los cuales la democracia
es usada por organizaciones terroristas
para mantener allí sus personas ha dicho
que es algo que se tiene que evitar
Christian ha dicho que va a seguir todos
los compromisos adquiridos con Turquía
que fueron adquiridos el pasado mes de
junio en Madrid en la Cumbre de la otan
por la que a través de la cual se
certificó la entrada de Finlandia y
Suecia a el proceso para entrar
definitivamente a la ota en este proceso
sin embargo aún no ha terminado Porque
todos los estados miembros de la otan
tienen que ratificar la entrada de un
nuevo país a través de sus parlamentos
faltan dos que voten a favor de la
entrada de Finlandia Suecia la otan son
el de Hungría y el de Turquía Turquía de
hecho sigue con este veto
sobre todo por la razón en que Turquía
quiere que se deporten a supuestos
miembros de organizaciones terroristas
sobre todo el pkk ha considerado
terrorista tanto por Turquía como para
la Unión Europea y la cofradía de efecto
lagunen desde Suecia y Finlandia hacia
Turquía Turquía el mes de junio pasó una
lista de 70 alto en torno a 70 personas
que Turquía quería deportadas Solo han
sido cuatro y los demás de momento no la
han sido nos espera que lo hagan por el
hecho de que es la justicia sueca la que
tiene que decir caso por caso de hecho
nos espera que el veto Turco sea
retirado hasta finales de primavera del
año que viene incluso entrado al verano
Turquía en junio tiene que celebrar unas
elecciones presidenciales cruciales para
el futuro tanto de erdogan como del país
sanatorio